في المعادله الايرانيه الضغوط للتغيير بل
لقلب المعادله اكبر من فجوه جيلين الاكراد
والبلوش هم اكثر السكان مشاركه في
الاحتجاجات والشعوب غير الفارسيه اصلا
تشكل 60% من السكان لا شعارات قوميه او
مذهبيه خلال الاحتجاجات كلها موجهه ضد
خامنئي ونظامه
م من السنه وهذا ما يفسر مهاجمه النظام
لمولوي عبد الحميد زعيم السنه الذي يصعد
بين الحين والاخر التصريحاته ضد النظام
لكن رغم ذلك الاعلام الحكومي الايراني
الانفصاليه خرج الخامنائي قبل ايام ليحذر
من الاختلافات المذهبيه والقوميه
اسلام دربارين نظام هناك وحده في الراي
بين الناس حول الاسلام وحول الثوره لا
تدعو هذه الوحده في الراي تختفي لا تدعم
الخلافات كالاختلافات العرقيه والاختلافات
المذهبيه وتحريض مشاعر مجموعه ضد مجموعه
اخرى